if you beat charlie today and you beat code
miko you go to the uh the winner's bracket
then you play i don't know whoa oh if i had known
that i would have did what i did last time and
learned his first 10 moves you can't
learn my moves i'm unpredictable jimmy
i literally would have went through it and
watched every game of chess you've ever played
you'd have to set aside a
whole year to watch my games
all right release your last 100 darn it okay
all right well regardless we'll see how it goes
oh i didn't even realize they started they
started and charlie busts out the uh the dutch
the dutch defense by charlie
and wait a second has he
removed his face this doesn't work yes he has
yes he has wha uh-huh i'm free moving baby
those squares are moved with red have you noticed
jimmy beast is making actual moves have you seen
wow he lets
five moves after pushing f5 the rest of
the kingside development was pre-moved
if if mr beast had some pre-move training and he
noticed what charlie was doing he could have tried
to take advantage of the pre-moves yes that well
he yeah that wow that was some savage stuff that
would have been really tragic can you imagine if
charlie just got caught with something my god um
but charlie plays h4 uh sorry mr beast has played
h4 i love it i love it especially if he gets h5
and then sacrifices that's never [ __ ] it's like
naradinsky's own playing style but being played
against charlie did he just say he doesn't have
a plan wait he just he just took instantly what
do this checkmated very soon if he continues
this way charlie danger danger hey is the
best move knight takes h7 not necessarily
and then bishop h5 pawn h5 and like queen
h5 like what is the best move here for
white i feel like the best move is f4
or something ridiculous like just daniel showed
me something like this and i forgot how it goes
well it's basically just actually
a little sack yep but in this case
bishop takes he he knows it he remembers
but not super precisely but he he's got it
i wonder if mr beast will realize that as
tempting as it is to capture the knight
on h5 oh well he goes for it the knight on g5 is
hanging that's the only issue with this attack wow
look at charlie he's he doesn't even take back
that's beautiful observation there if charlie
takes that knight the game's going to end a lot
faster because in my prediction because the attack
is nerfed a little bit e4 realizing that that
creates a discovered attack and he feels good
about it mr b is feeling good about the discovered
attack it could have been a brilliant move if it
wasn't for this this capture or oh actually
wait uh bishop f3 traps the queen charlie
two blunder charlie also blundered yeah wasn't
the best but queen takes g2 was not the right
reaction yeah actually i don't know what the right
way probably f4 just shutting the door on the
bishop but it was really complex i thought queen
takes g2 for the first sight at first oh my god
oh i hope he doesn't see it
uh oh man see charlie's problem oh my
god i just saw it oh my queen can be
my queen can be trapped i'd
be lined a little too hard
he's right and trying to play he's very shitty
spot if he sees it i wonder if he spots the
opportunity that queen he's now trapped mr b
is the underdog in this match that's huge going
for it my queen is now trapped wow yeah that's
amazing uh now charlie's gotta really slow down
or actually he might speed up even more because
he sees beast got a minute and 40. this is not
a position a 700 rated player wants to play with
a minute and 40 on the clock oh my gosh charlie
had to get rid of the knight he is not fighting
on equal footing like he has to get his pieces
out that is the issue i know we're looking at
this from beast perspective so all beast needs
to do is play boop boop and get something going
maybe boop sneak in here take on d4 now since
the knight has moved away from the protection
of the d4 pro and it's it's free stuff yes he
plays king b1 so again it's charlie's moment he's
got to get the rest of the pieces out oh my god
he is charlie's gone off the deep end but frankly
jimmy's got 15 seconds i hope he'll turn that flag
c2 and now he hung the house oh it's done
mate it's not just hanging the rook it's mate
oh can we cut the truck gotcha can we
get the close call pikachu no gifted subs
oh okay well that was far less
dramatic that was i mean okay all right
fine we get e4 i wonder if he's gonna play the
same opening uh that we did last time okay so
this time he just goes for e5 the problem with
this and not playing what he played against ludwig
is the fact that charlie is prepared with
the vienna and this could be a short game
uh charlie got the vienna from uh
i don't know some guy but whoa f5
f5 this is an anti-vienna gambit if we want
to refer to it that way uh well charlie's
just going to take right otherwise so many
vienna lines and i have never seen this ever
in my life okay the reason why d4 is strong i
was just gonna add that he still has queen h5
and mr beast realized that the pawn on e5 was
hanging so he's guarding it now with the knight
good thinking but it doesn't solve the bigger
issue which existed prior to d4 yeah queen h5
is still winning of course even de5 95 is totally
winning for white just and he's played it i think
now the best move for black is d4 using that open
space hitting the knight removing your pawn out of
danger and only then taking back and i don't know
i don't know maybe beast will take on f5 maybe e5
what's he gonna do i wonder which capture
will he go for if he takes any of those pawns
bishop takes f5 would be the best option out of
the captures because that prevents queen h5 but d4
look at you lovey you worked with the mr beast
for an hour and now he's thinking like you know
by the way chad i should say d4 is still losing
because of queen h5 but we're just pretending
that that will never get played so if you add the
little exception that queen h5 cannot get played
because clearly no one's going to play it or
concerned about it yeah blind spot charlie
didn't see it when it was possible straight away
yeah and then he had a second chance he didn't
see it now this is his third chance but the more
the longer it's there on the board the more likely
that he still will not spot it it is a blind spot
he's not looking at that queen check we could go
it really is not a nice one uh daniel that takes
him so much time jimmy's got me [ __ ] flustered
i'll tell you what no he doesn't charlie no
he doesn't you got yourself flustered jeez i'm
sure okay i've played like a thousand three minute
games over the last three months and i've done
vienna and almost all of them i've never
seen someone push this f pawn that's for a
reason charlie for a reason usually it's either
here a knight a knight sometimes even a bishop
but i've never seen that for a reason okay
all right anyway yeah it's not that he uh
that he messed up well beast the thing
is beast also just went all in and
yeah knight takes knight here
and that's yeah beast beast i told him i was
like you go to war sometimes without developing
all the pieces and this is you know that's the
thing chess is a very unforgiving game uh it's
your bad habits catch up to you especially
if you don't actively try to like
improve them and anna anna having said that
if knight d4 c5 i was gonna say there's
it's not that simple to counter this
charlie is up a piece but in order to
keep the piece he has to find bishop d2 best
move charlie's charlie's definitely sharp
yeah charlie's just got to keep focused here it
can be really difficult to play people who have
five seconds because you just it's like non-stop
and boom like right now rook c6 best move take the
pawn with check take he misses it attacks the
rook b's got to see the rook does under attack
three two one one beast oh back to that square oh
he took it this time now he takes it i think that
might be it i think that might be it now beast
is still firing off moves oh he's starting c4 yep
charlie can take yeah and now the rook's
getting out of there he's kicking the rook out
0.9 seconds when mr beast made his final move
g6 clean clean clean rookie 7 rookie 7 is gonna
happen now oh king c7 take the okay that's just
and there it is beast resigns the game and charlie
an emphatic game fashion oh
basically prime fire and resub icaku
go go dad uh but anyways regardless uh ggs
you got the best of me um and what what'd
you think of the game i thought it was good
man when you trapped my queen i was like yep
jimmy saw it yeah that was not an easy move to
spot there was a move uh deep in the second game
where i actually could put my rook in front of one
of your pawns and i didn't see it yeah i just yeah
i just looked at that i was so preoccupied with
moving my knight i didn't even look at my pawn
because my gut told me too i was like i guarantee
you he doesn't see it i was like there's just
something about how weird this board is he's gonna
be so focused over here i was like i'm gonna get
away with this and i did yeah but not the second
time the second time uh second time i got it
charlie was like question for you because you know
you gotta you got obviously the prophet uh and uh
he's watching he's watching your games you ever
like hear his voice in your head i know we did
a lesson or two but it's not the same you got a
full-time coach seriously you ever hear his voice
like what he's gonna say to you when he's done
your games are done jesus yeah absolutely it's i
can already hear it a hundred percent the ravings
of a mad man the pre moves i know he did not enjoy
and then uh in the second game when you pushed
that f-pawn i'd never seen it before i i played so
many vienna games but i've never seen the f-pawn
push so i didn't know how to react at all and
i missed a huge sequence if i went over to the h
file and i know he was screaming he probably threw
his coffee cup on the ground and just flipped over
his table does it feel like like like you're a
chess kid and he's a chess parent a little bit
like you come out of the tournament room and
you're like i won and he's like you missed seven
moves and yeah that's absolutely how that feels
it feels like he's the strictest chess parent ever
yeah i i enjoyed pog champs was so much more fun
than i thought it would be um i i assume this is
your second one because i saw that clip on youtube
where you checkmated hqc or whatever um yeah we
don't even remember his name it was so brutal
and so now that i've experienced it next time i'm
in one i'm definitely gonna train a lot like this
was a lot of fun uh you're not done oh wait yeah
please don't say goodbye no no no you're yeah
you're not done you got you got a game in like
a day or two against code mika all right but
now i'm like doomed to lose like there's no way i
win no i think you've got a great chance against
that's the crazy thing but that's like the petty
game like it's like you know what i'm gonna do
the bottom of the bottom listen jimmy draw some
inspiration you got a guy here who last time he
played in this event was around the same strength
you are now right and then charlie worse yeah
okay i didn't say that you said that but you went
to the consolation bracket and then you won it
you